body understand I'm going to look into
this camera right here so I hope you see
me I want everybody to understand and
remember that everything I say from this
point she backed it up all right so it's
basically zero all right you have no
hope no chance past the 20 years and
that comes from experience it also is
the experience you have no chance of
passing 20 years you're saying no no you
can pass 20 years and probably be
roommates and you'll probably be
overweight in a bust that Pillsbury
biscuit can or you'll probably be with
the exception to the rule but the data
shows us plus the experience that she
expressed that it's a very difficult
thing and this is what I want men to
know yeah it is very difficult many
people will simplify it for you they
will say oh just do this and do that and
they will lead you on a wild goose chase
and that's my perspective that's all
that I offer I tell men to not get
married especially when you don't have
leverage however I also tell you do not
listen to people who simplify this this
is a very complicated thing that most
people fail at miserably got it
because you used a few things there yeah
about not getting married you said
sometimes you're trying to leverage okay
if you don't have leverage we'll talk
about that yeah and you talk about
turning into roommates well this guy is
the roommate the host of The Roommate
channel right
um when you're hearing this you've been
married one year and by the way this
guy's a sharp informed very intentional
guy he's my assumption is he didn't just
trip and fall into marriage he's seen
myself before okay gotcha so you've been
you've been very you're a calculated
dude okay so when you're hearing Greg
say this yeah and even when you're
hearing Ali say this how are you
processing this this is really good and
I'm excited about how this conversation
can developed because I think you've
maybe did you react to me in ams's
conversation a couple years ago about
marriage I didn't react to it I didn't
do reaction video but yeah I made a
comment about okay you made a comment
about it okay so um so to me I'm really
excited about it but it's also key to
talk about experience experience shapes
review right yeah so a girl who's been
abused by a lot of different men she's
gonna have a very cynical meaning View
towards men a man who's been cheated by
business partners will be a very cynical
view about having potential business
partners so it's also unique to talk
about where does my yet we have to be
honest nobody here is 100 objective
that's one of my arguments always with
red pill stuff instead of speaking the
truth and you're not a robot you know
you're you have your biases right call
it for what it is we all have our biases
I have biases you have biases coach has
biases as much as we think we are we
have to be 100 honest to the people
about our biases if I'm an individual
and I was divorced and I had a difficult
experience via marriage I'm gonna have a
biased opinion via marriage Ali has a
positive experience with marriage so she
can have a bias towards well great
marriages can work right so seems
similar to me the people I admire the
most the people I look up to are married
People Patrick David Jordan Peterson my
father Pastor Mark Driscoll people who I
look up to the most right long-term
marriages the people that I celebrate a
lot longer long-term marriage is my
father and mother been married for over
30 years great healthy marriage so
that's my opinion my pastor Pastor Heidi
Lewis been married over 25 years so I
that's my world view and so to me
hearing what he's saying sharing there
is truth in that everything where
everyone's going to share is going to be
truth in it yes if you like my dad told
me a very powerful boy I love my father
he's so such a wise older man he said
the most important decision you'll ever
make in your life is the one you marry
and it can and it can go one of two ways
and this is the this is what I want the
guys to understand we're not teaching
naivete which is oh marriage is perfect
thing and you just meet the one and live
happily ever after and there's no issues
there's no divorces that's we're not
teaching naivete marriage can be the
worst thing in your life it can be an
absolute living hell and I guarantee you
you can go for days and for days and you
know so many different stories about
people with marriage is an absolute
living hell but we don't want to teach
being being naive about the realities
but also we don't want to teach nihilism
right the other end of the extreme
marriage is the worst thing possible and
women are out to get your money and
everyone's miserable and everybody's
roommates and everybody is this because
they are some individuals such as what
Alex communicated who are in happy
healthy long-term marriage right so you
don't want to be naive you want to be
nihilistic you want to be as real as
possible give me the good the bad and
ugly and my biggest thing is that I
understand that marriage is a very
difficult thing to get right and and the
same thing is like I love how what you
do is marriage and money right I think
we're gonna be talking about those two
things today Adam you're a one percent
man financially right that means 99 of
people are trying to get to where Adam
is most people live paycheck to paycheck
they're struggling their lives suck when
it comes to money most people are
struggling but they're trying to get
where to where you are that's how I view
relationships most people are in really
sucky relationship most people it's a
day-to-day War hell the way work is the
way the gym is but then there are some
people who are having it at the highest
of level the same way we don't nobody
says oh well most people are not going
to be in the one percent so it's true it
you should even try it's oh my oh yeah
you know 90 of businesses ending in in
10 years you should even try we say if
somebody's gonna succeed why not use
which I love what you're doing if
someone's going to be rich why not you
if someone's gonna make money why not
you someone could have a great podcast
why not you so for me I acknowledge that
that the top of the mountain is rare I
acknowledge that but what I also
acknowledge is that if somebody's gonna
win why why not it be you and how can we
help as many men as possible get there
everybody won't be able to get there but
how many people how many people can we
help get there and that's what to me
matters the most strange I love that now
when you hear something
jeez
first of all right
I said wait till the other guy responds
oh okay go on there's just one more part
hold on like this obviously he's sort of
saying all right I hear you coach your
marriage didn't work you got out you
know thank God before the 10-year Mark
so you'd probably be a little bit more
spiteful than you are not saying that
you're spiteful but you'll be even more
spiteful if you're paying a ridiculous
amount of alimony and everything you've
been paying but is there anything wrong
with that if he's saying he's basically
saying I hear you coach It Ain't Easy
out there brother like life's tough
marriage is tough getting making money
is tough things are tough but don't tell
me that I shouldn't get married or don't
tell me that I can't have a successful
marriage how do you process that I don't
think anyone said
I think they caution people to say do
not get married if I say do not get
married without leverage that is a
position right that you can change thus
if you read my book it says once you get
to that position you can then make the
decision you'll probably come out better
yeah than going in it without it however
this is what I will always say when men
do find that that solution does not work
out
they are left alone
there's nobody to help them so people
encourage people hey why not give it a
try but when you go bankrupt when you
lose your kids when your kids are taken
from you when the courts kind of punish
you for making this decision or punish
you it punishes you for being a slightly
better higher earner then nobody's there
with information nobody's there with
context no one's there to help them and
I believe not feel I know understand
believe and I have evidence to show that
men are left alone when they don't
succeed in this endeavor and that is the
void that I feel because I can tell you
hey men are alone in this situation men
are homeless men are thinking about
eating guns men are thinking about they
have no way out men are losing big time
and we're losing a fraction of men
through due to manipulation due to
people trying to you know they may be
heard a woman might be hurting a
marriage or she might feel that she's
not being appreciated and then she
throws a grenade in the room what
happens then see that's what where I
come in I get to show you what happens
when the grenade is there and I also
encourage you you're not alone in this a
lot of people come to my content and
they find out oh you too see before as I
said 70 years ago 40 years ago 30 years
ago there was nobody presenting this
side of the artist I see what you're
saying this right here nobody they just
left me in alone and they said well you
must not have been hitting it right or
you must not have loved it right or you
must have abused the kids that's what
she said she said that you were and
nobody came to this position so I
listened there was a void open and I ran
right yeah so so if you're like okay
geez yeah can I first say that
Hafeez knows how to speak
without saying a lot
first of all
um but go on what did you want to ask
after that I wanted to see what you guys
what'd you guys think about clip
um were you paying attention China
was on his phone
why are you holding me up for
you what would you think yeah it was
good it was good what'd you like about
it
I think there's quite a lot of
information to take in but I think the
guy the black guy in the suit we're
getting a suit on in the middle I think
he had a lot of valid points and it goes
back to choice you choose to be I think
it's a certain type of person that
chooses to be
married or the traditional way of living
when I think of like my parents or my
auntie's uncles they got married within
about 21 or 24. normal
the start yeah I can look at differently
so I know Martin and uncle are give them
as an example yeah they look and act
like they are still in love of each
other all the time okay it's a it's a
very nice unit
and
but then there's other examples I have
that it doesn't necessarily that's
something that you aspire to what to
have that type of relationship I used to
growing up I feel like as a girl you
kind of get taught this um fairy tale
way of Love or fairy tale way of being
like you you get married you have kids
you do this you do that and I did really
Aspire for marriage I would like to get
married one day but it's not now like if
it doesn't happen it's the end of my
life if that makes sense so if you you
said you'd want to get married and if
you don't it's not the end of end of the
world
um
why do you think that changed
um
you kind of wake up when you get into
real life and adulthood and you see how
relationships work does something like
when I go think about the type of person
I am how relationships work and you have
to see through The Good the Bad and the
Ugly people change things change Money
Changes how you your parents might
change you might get into an accident
certain things that you have to want to
love on that person regardless of what
happens is deeper than just the day and
I think growing up you just see the
wedding dress you think I'm gonna invite
all my girls we're going to do this we
do that but after that point it's you
and that person dude do you get what I'm
saying yeah that because for me I
personally believe that
one of the reasons why the divorce rate
is so high at all what oh the reason why
women are the ones initiating divorces
because like you said they were sold a
Hollywood version yeah of what
relationship was and so what happens is
when they actually get into it they
realize that it's actually not what
they've been sold because women are kind
of grown on Disney movies and
rom-coms right and they believe that
relationships should be a certain way
and then what happens is when they get
into them they realize that it's
actually work do you know what I mean
like relationships are actually working
and so I feel like
to quote I feel like I feel like women
don't understand what relationships
actually are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible